mob violence we've been seeing from the
left it's nothing new in fact this has
been around since Ronald Reagan was
governor of California in the 1960s and
he had his own way though of dealing
with the problem joining us now with
insight it's important to get some
reagan biographer presidential historian
Craig Shirley Craig I've been dying to
talk to you as the temperature is rising
though you get the sense especially with
social media that's a big difference
between now and back in nineteen sixty
nine people are able to coalesce in a
place really fast and assault people in
public places either verbally or
otherwise
but how did Reagan deal with it and how
might we learn from that he Lord he deal
dealt with a lot of wit and grace it was
I remember one time during the Vietnam
War he was confronted by a smelly
malodorous dirty disheveled hippie and
it may have been Bill Clinton probably
no but the hippie was carrying a sign
that said make love not war Reagan
looked at the hippie and he looked at
the sign he turned to an aide he says
you know from the looks of him I don't
think he do either so he had a way of
yeah one time you was in his use it as
limo the berkeley again there was a
group of unruly students out there
anti-war protesters and they were making
a scene and make him you know making
themselves obnoxious reagan got a piece
of paper and wrote on the piece of paper
and put up the windshield and it said
i'm selling my bonds he had a way of
dealing with these things but you know
by turning humor to his advantage which
can be a great asset in american
politics yeah you see trump in recent
days at these rallies he's actually been
extremely funny but at the same time
very good but at the same time it's it's
it's a different environment media wise
the media was against reagan hated
reagan was president but there's
something different about the way the
clips on social media are shared but i
do want to play something for you this
is from nineteen sixty-nine and this is
um in a public meeting with the berkeley
administration during all of the chaos
on campus let's watch all of it began
the first time some of you who know
better and are old enough to know better
let young people think that they had the
right to choose the laws they would obey
as long as they were doing it in the
name of social protest boy is that
appropriate for today's time I mean what
are we teaching the kids you can you can
trash something pull down a statue
because you don't like it give the you
know middle finger to the president
because you know someone gave you the
lines to say he broke it down to its
elements into its components and he
revealed what was really going on there
which was just wasn't about social
justice it was about creating injustice
look this is the essential difference
between the Tea Party of some years ago
and the protesters of today is that the
Tea Party was defending institutions the
protesters of today are trying to tear
down institutions and that's the
essential difference between the two
yeah I think the you've heard from some
of the individuals who've gotten in the
faces of these senators and they say
they want to they want to take it all
down there's a piece of the house posted
a by one of them they want to take it
down it's not about winning out on it a
particular point or even a Supreme Court
seat it's about taking down the entire
framework which is just fomenting
injustice against various minority group
world would air view we're witnessing
the twenty first version of the French
Revolution the French Revolution as you
recall was about tearing down all
institutions in France destroying
everything marriage contracts money
government property everything in order
to achieve what they call the time
social justice and that's what the
modern left anti protesters and Tifa
protest is about is about destroying all
fabric of society in order to start over
and everybody supposedly starts out on
an even playing field okay I'm hoping we
hide all the guillotines at this point
Craig Shirley thanks so much for joining
us